bonjour mesdames et messieurs nous avons
eu une conversation très consistante
avec leur représentant de l'union
européenne pour les affaires étrangères
est pour les politiques de sécurité josé
baroeul et son équipe
nous avons discuté en détail l'état des
relations actuelles entre la russie et
l'union européenne
il est évident que ces relations pas si
sûr vite des moments pas simple ce qui
lie avec des restrictions unilatérales
qui sont introduits par l'union
européenne pour des raisons non imaginer
nous en avons déjà parlé aujourd'hui il
est important à mon point de vue que les
deux côtés ont fait preuve de leur
intérêt à maintenir et élargir le
dialogue y compris pour des questions de
divergences qui n'y sont assez nombreux
nous sommes prêts à poursuivre notre
coopération là où on trouve l'intérêt
pour le des parties nous avons des
pignons commune que la dégradation
ultérieure de nos relations a peut-être
dur en conséquence nous comptons à ce qu
au au cours de cet aperçu stratégique
des relations avec la russie qui est
prévue à l'union européenne pour le mois
de mars de l'année en cours à durant le
sommet ordinaire
nous espérons que le choix sera fait
mais pour en en dialogue constructif
professionnel à pragmatique les
différents persisteront il est évident
qu'il faut réduire leur nombre mais nous
restons voisins et nous avons notre
responsabilité commune pour maintenir la
stabilité à notre continent européen
eurasiatique cette responsabilité pour
assurer le maximum de confort pour le
citoyen à cet espace géopolitique énorme
d'autant plus que nous sommes liés avec
les pays européens par des liens
culturels notre histoire de plusieurs
siècles et il est évident que nous avons
beaucoup de points communs dans
l'économie a bien qu à comparer avec
l'année 2012 ou 2013
roche nos échanges à ont été réduits à
deux morts au même endroit mais l'union
européenne et reste notre partenaire le
plus important du point de vue
économique les businessmen de l'union
européenne restait des investisseurs les
plus importants au parmi les plus
importants à l'économie russe
nonobstant de la pandémie les indices
majeurs des échanges commerciales et
reste dans le plh positif
je crois qu'une relation et notera en en
terre dépendance doit être utilisée au
profit des deux côtés nous avons cette
compréhension que nous allons chercher
d'autres points d'appliquer nos efforts
communs pour créer pour restaurer nos
relations nous avons parlé aujourd'hui
de la santé publique y est d un
changement climatique de la science de
l'éducation
bref ces deux mêmes ou les experts les
ministres des dus à côté sont en mesure
de préparer d'un désaccord importants et
nous essayerons de n'est pas faire
traîner ce dossier si nos collègues
européens y sont prêtes
cette volonté a été confirmée durant
notre entretien aujourd'hui nous avons
la volonté de poursuivre le dialogue
politique
cet entretien d'aujourd'hui a réaffirmé
l'importance de ce dialogue et
nonobstant de cadres actuels nous avons
des perspectives à développer y compris
la lutte contre le terrorisme contre le
trafic des drogues
y reste très était très important pour
l'afghanistan ainsi que pour d'autres
vecteurs nous avons prêté une attention
particulière à la situation au proche
orient et au nord de l'afrique nous
avons au parler de règlement du conflit
arabo-israélien nous avons des approches
comment a pour l'heure la restauration
de l'activité des intermédiaires de
quatre intermédiaires pour le dossier
décroche rien nous avons cette
compréhension de nécessité d'utiliser
les pôles et impossibilité de ce groupe
dans deux médiateurs pour restaurer le
dialogue direct entre les palestiniens
et les israéliens pour le pour aider les
parties à trouver la solution qui
s'inscrirait à cette formule de deux
états qui a été confirmée à dans le
cadre de l'onu et dans le cadre de cette
initiative est rabat nous avons aussi
entamé de nombreuses redditions de crise
et compris à la syrie et la libye nous
comprenons que l'instabilité qui reste
dans cette région continue à exercer une
mauvaise influence à titre global y
compris les questions des réfugiés qui
n'est pas résolu
il faut bien sûr traiter ces questions
mais ne pas oublier l'histoire de cet
événement et les pv dans que les
problèmes seraient moins nombreux si à
l'époque de nombreux états occidentaux à
s'obstine bray bsd aventure en afrique
et au proche orient
nous allons poursuivre notre activité
pour régler le problème du nucléaire
iranien
maintenant sept ans au moment critique
et nous comptons à ce que
l'administration américaine conduite par
six de ces négociations à de cet accord
nous avons donc eu la partie américaine
étudiera la possibilité de restaurer cet
accord qui a été considéré comme un
exemple de la diplomatie internationale
visant à réduire la tension dans les
points chauds et pour la production
prolifération des armes nucléaires nous
sommes prêtes à coopérer pour tout un
éventail d'autres au conflit y compris
de différents problèmes à l'échelle
régionale nous allons poursuivre à en
informer les ans les autres cours des
différentes questions de notre
coopération judiciaire exprimer notre
regret que durant cette période de
pandémie qui devrait le forcer à nous
unir et agir ensemble on trouve
certaines forces au sein de l'union
européenne qui profite ce sujet pour
accusé la russie de la désinformation
il me semble que la russie et par ses
actes a prouvé sa volonté à aider tous
les collègues intéressés y compris à de
l'union à l'union européenne pour lutter
contre ce virus est dangereux
si nous voulons vraiment à arrêter ces
guerres d'information il me semble que
nous devons créer avec l'union
européenne encore au canal pour que ces
discussions sur la désinformation soit à
basée à des fêtes qui ne ce qui me
permettrait de traiter d'affaires au
niveau professionnel
notre proposition reste en vigueur je
tiens aussi mentionné qu'une somme prête
à discuter des questions qui sont liées
avec les intentions de l'union
européenne pour les pays de l'ex union
européenne il s'agit de l'asie centrale
et du caucase où l'union européenne de
faire preuve d'un intérêt accru
nous allons compter à ce que les
intérêts légitimes de la fédération de
russie
or pour les relations avec nos alliés
nos voisins seront prises en
considération par l'union européenne
lors de la construction de sa politique
a dans ce domaine dans ce régime dans
cette région
il me semble qu'il serait raisonnable de
d'établir les principes qui est serait
basé à l'engagement de non ingérence
adea ferrat antérieures des états
indépendants à l'espace de l'ex union
européenne est partout dans le monde
notre discussion d'aujourd'hui a été
franchi nous n'avons pas caché nos
différents mais nos activités visent à
discuter les différents ne pas cacher
les offenses au contraire nos sont
prêtés renforcer nos contacts nous y
sont prêtes et nos collègues nous ont
fait preuve de la même opinion de la
part de l'union européenne je tiens à
remercier à leur présentant son équipe
pour à ces négociations qui ont eu un
succès je vous remercie mais sur le rove
pour votre invitation pour cette
opportunité à avoir cette discussion
franche et ouverte comme vous venez de
lui dire non négociation ont été assez
intense s'est pas terminée pour le
moment nous allons poursuivre nos
contacts après la conférence de presse
l'objectif de ma visite consiste à
discuter les différends et les points
compliquées auxquelles nous faisons face
et surtout pour les sujets où nous avons
défendu différent et il est évident
qu'une devons mentionné que ces
dernières années nos relations ont connu
des différends majeurs ont souffert de
manque de confiance et maintenant nous
ne ressentons plus que concurrents que
comme des partenaires
nonobstant de ce fait à l'union
européenne reste le majeur partenaire
commercial de la russie et restent une
source majeure d'investissement pour la
fédération des aussi les étudiants
russes sont le groupe le plus important
des étudiants étrangers qui touchent des
bourses pour différents problèmes dans
différents établissements de
l'enseignement supérieur
la russie est notre plus grand voisin a
alors la relance et action avec ce pays
a une importance énorme pour tous les
pays de l'union européenne mais des
événements internes et externes ont créé
encadrent compliqué pour développer les
relations dont nous avons rêvé pendant
les années 90 lorsque nous avons parlé
de l'europe de lisbonne à vladivostok
maintenant les choses sont beaucoup plus
compliquées qu'il y à une vingtaine ou
une trentaine d'années ma visite est
tenue la semaine même de l'arrestation
de
d'alexis navalni et de milliers de
manifestants
je fais part monsieur lavrov de ma
préoccupation à ce sujet et je lui
adressait à mon appel à libérer navalni
et a réalisé une enquête complète de son
empoisonnement
avec tout mon respect pour la
souveraineté de la russie et
l'engagement de l'est russie pour dans
le cadre international
je tiens à rappeler que la fédération
russe et est lié par les principes de la
primauté de la loi et l'engagement de
respect des droits de l'homme et des
libertés fondamentales et qui est reste
importante pour l'union européenne et
pour les russies a il ya des domaines où
nous pouvons et nous devons coopérer
ce qui nous permettait d'attendre le bon
résultat
monsieur le ministre a déjà mentionné
certains mais je répète que dans le
domaine de la culture de la santé
publique la lutte contre la copie de 19
les travaux en afrique que les mesures
contre les changements climatiques et
les mesures dans le domaine informatique
nos offres les opportunités à travailler
pour l'enterrer comment à l'échiquier
international comme j'ai déjà dit
monsieur le ministre il ne reste des
domaines où nous pouvons peut-être
rallier ne pouvons coopérer
ça concerne les processus des règlements
proches rien pour resterez le travail du
groupe de médiateurs et a invité la
demie la nouvelle administration des
états unis à reprendre sa participation
en ce qui concerne le va lutter contre
les changements climatiques
l'union européenne est acquis dans le
domaine ce qui nous offre une plateforme
pour la coopération à bilatérales
nous espérons que la fédération de
russie participera à la suivante
conférence des parties de la convention
et apporta apportera sa contribution à
créer un nouveau cadre pour la réduction
de l'utilisation des combustibles
conformément à l'acte celle qui la
stabilité en europe est basé au respect
des seuils en été et des frontières des
états ainsi qu respect des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
il nous faut trouver en langage comment
et les hommes pouvant de de coopération
ma visite ce n'est que le premier panne
les différents reste mais ne seront en
quête des solutions et des vecteurs de
coopération bonjour très star hip hop
l'agent spoutnik monsieur morel
je suis convaincu que la question des
droits des libertés doit rester au coeur
des relations entre la russie et
l'europe l'union européenne a les
responsables auraient péan et ont évolué
de manière différente de la situation
avec la loi de liberté en russie vous
avez fait part de votre évolution dans
le contexte de la sphère navalni et
quant à moi je suis préoccupé également
par la situation des droits et des
libertés sur le sol européen
un mur en européenne le 3 décembre
dernier mes collègues journalistes ont
été arrêtés en lettonie
des perquisitions ont été effectuées
contre ce journaliste et il y à des
poursuites engagées
ils sont accusés d'avoir violé le régime
de sanctions de l'union européenne
contre la fédération de russie et les
médias russes avec lesquels ces
journalistes ont coopéré notamment l'
agence d'information bagnoud cela gens
se foutent nique les ressources du
groupe média rossi s et gogniat ne
figure sur aucune liste des sanctions de
l'union européenne
le journaliste mentionnait ne sont pas
inclus dans aucune liste des personnes
contre lesquelles les sanctions avaient
été imposées j'estime qu'il s'agit d'une
violation des droits et des libertés de
séjour des citoyens de la lettonie
d'avoir accès à l'information les droits
de ce journaliste d'exercer leur
profession leur métier il ya quelques
jours nous avons fait face des actions
part et de la part de l'autre haine
contre leurs journalistes ou trois
chaînes ont été bloqués monsieur borel
êtes vous prêts à utiliser votre
autorité politique vos ressources
administratives votre volonté pour
résoudre la situation avec le
journaliste en lettonie et les
journalistes ukrainiens contre
lesquelles ces états utilisent les
mesures de pression leur privant le
droit d'exercer leur métier
merci et si c'est possible j'ai une
deuxième question monsieur borel
récemment il ya eu là la troisième
réunion du conseil conjoint cuba union
européenne et vous
vous avez co présidé cette réunion
comment voulez-vous en général la
situation des relations entre l'europe
et cuba et pensez vous que ce format
plus donner un élan pour réduire les
tensions entre havas et vaches hington
des états unis et
si possible je voudrais adresser la même
question mais cela prouve comment voulez
vous la politique de l'union européenne
à l'égard de cuba
merci en ce qui concerne cuba
je suis un peu étonné parce que je me
suis pas entendu avoir cette question à
moscou mais pourquoi pas j'ai rien
cacher concernant les relations entre
l'union européenne et cuba
oui nous avons un dialogue politique et
un accord de coopération a d'après
lequel noah les on les change et la
coopération dans plusieurs domaines
je suis planté à savoir pourquoi ça vous
intéresser tellement il n'y a rien de
nouveau dans ce domaine il n'ya pas
longtemps j'ai co présidé la réunion
avec le ministre des affaires étrangères
de cubains messieurs rodrigues lors de
laquelle et nous avons négocié les
priorités de notre coopération d'ici
2020 7 avec l'accent fait sur la
modernisation de l'économie et la
transition écologique
on n'est pas sans savoir que l'union
européenne renonce refuse l'embargo
imposé par les états unis nous avons
réaffirmé notre position auprès de la
nouvelle administration un des états
unis je pense que c'est tout ce que je
peux dire à cet égard nos espérances que
l'administration américaine envisage sa
position à l'égard de cuba et nous
poursuivrons notre dialogue
politique pour les domaines de
coopération de jeu en viande est
mentionné en ce qui concerne ces
événements liés avec les interpellations
des journalistes
en dix ans les demies je vous savez tous
les pays de l'union européenne respecte
le principe de primauté de la loi et la
protection des droits de l'homme je suis
persuadé que le système judiciaire
letton a en vertu des engagements de ces
pays devraient les rats cette enquête a
est un guidée par les principes de la
légalité et en plein respect des droits
de l'homme et le citoyen alors en ce qui
concerne les relations avec l'union
européenne et cuba
je vois aucune surprise parce que moi
lorsque je ferai une visite plusieurs
pays on me pose toujours des questions
sur le cren voilà et vous êtes en visite
en russie héros pose des questions sur
cuba parce que c'est un ps et un homme
portant et je crois qu nous avons là un
exemple positif de beaune raisonnement
qui a permis de me permet d'éviter à la
pression unilatérale la douceur d'un
embargo de blocus et nous avec l'union
européenne nous avons la même approche
qui consiste à essayer de résoudre
toutes sortes de problème est différent
uniquement à en dialoguant et la
pression de force des ultimatums des
sanctions qui touchent tout ce qu'ils
veulent développer de nos relations
toutes sortes de restrictions ex
territoriale alors là ce sont des outils
et des méthodes du passé colonial et
nous avons parlé aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
malheureusement l'union européenne à
utilisent de plus en plus ces outils et
qui ont été inventés par les états unis
nous le déplorons et j'espère que
des événements international prochain y
compris le sommet des membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité qui a été proposé
par président poutine
hier monsieur lacroix a réaffirmé son
soutien à cette initiative
il me semble que ces événements
internationale devrait être utilisée
pour voir à quel monde sommes-nous en
train de construire au monde
multipolaire qui assurerait l'égalité de
tous les acteurs y compris évidemment
l'union européenne ou au monde
multilatéral qui ne sert à rien quand
propos pour justifier les utiles dans
monde unilatérale nous avons commencé ce
dialogue aujourd'hui nous allons le
poursuivre nous sommes persuadés que
c'est le format où tous les états se
verront leur place c'est l'organisation
des nations unies a lorsqu'on parle de
multilatéralisme efficace comme la
france par exemple l'a fait si on
commence à creuser
qu'est-ce qu'on s'entend à ce but le
latéral isme on voit que c'est l'union
européenne qui doit être leader et
donner l'exemple des leçons à tout le
monde
ce sont des questions petit fils autre
philosophie qui mais ils sont en lien
avec la politique réelle et je me
réjouis de la sincérité de notre échange
d'aujourd'hui pour des questions qui
nous avons les ans a posé aux autres il
me semble que c'est l'unique approche
raisonnable mais en ce qui concerne
l'exemple cuba on voit un très bien
1 la mauvaise influence d approche
unilatérale ce qui ne fait que prouver
la nécessité de les réexaminer
monsieur le ministre je peux donner un
commentaire en ce qui concerne les
questions sur cuba on a en cinéma cubain
les palmes ce neige et cette
conversation me rappeler ce film et j'ai
vu ajouter quelque chose à mes réponses
à puisque les journalistes américains
peuvent être intéressés nous avons
beaucoup ont regretté la décision de
transfert en conclure cuba dans la liste
des pays qui soutiennent le terrorisme
cette décision qui a été prise durant
les dernières heures de sa présidence et
je tiens à souligner qu'une déplorons
cette décision et nous espérons à ce que
la nouvelle administration restaure le
statu quo en annulant cette décision de
monsieur trempe qui ne fait qu aggraver
les choses pour les cubes an et pour les
relations économiques et commerciales
avec ce pays
j'existais ans messieurs borel avait dit
avant de partir pour moscou que les
relations entre l'union européenne et la
russie connaît un point bas
je tiens à vous poser une question pour
eux de savoir si on peut trouver une
solution il y à une question très très
aigu la pandémie a bloqué fait bloquer
les voyages entre la russie l'union
européenne et les russes qui habitent
une union européenne et les européens
qui habite en russie en devises à long
terme et les hommes d'affaires par
exemple d'autres groupes de gens font
face à de nombreux problèmes
un essayant de voyager entre la russie
et l'union européenne
on sait qu' il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
pu voir leur famille but de jeunes est
ce que la russie l'union européenne
peuvent trouver une solution qui
permettrait de résoudre ce problème nous
comprenons qu à cause de la pandémie en
les frontières ne peuvent pas être
ouvertes facilement mais il s'agit des
citoyens qui habitent hors européen qui
habite en russie et des russes qui
avaient tant européennes est ma deuxième
question était dressé mais sur la voie
ve
quand on parle de la même langue d
intérêt comment est ce que vous
envisagez levac sens pour nick v comme
un moyen de réunir moyen de
rapprochement entre la russie et l'union
européenne
ou comme un facteur qui peut
créer la divergence en ce qui concerne
les restruction de ce libre circulation
des voyages personne n'a pris de telles
mesures pour sa propre sont pas plaisir
ce sont les restrictions qui ont que
nous avons dû faire ampli qui pour des
italiens qui habite en russie et à vis
et versa mais pour d'autres personnes
tout ça et vise à limiter la propagation
de la pandémie de virus nous somme un
nous travaillons ensemble pour restaurer
ses relations à cette circulation entre
nos sociétés mais il faut le faire d'une
manière à sécuriser
alors évidemment actuellement il leur
est certaine réflexion pour des voyages
qui ne sont pas absolument nécessaires
et les pays de l'union européenne
apporte cette responsabilité pour la
mise à jour de ces restrictions et de
ses règles j'ai du mal à prévoir quand
est ce que les pays de l'union
européenne prendront la décision
d'ouvrir les frontières
donc il est d'autant plus important de
développer notre coopération pourra
mettre fin à cette pandémie
en ce qui concerne le vaccin ce pique
nique il s'agit pas vraiment à sa
possibilité de jouer un rôle positif non
il s'agit en fait de créer en
partenariat égal entre tous les
fabricants du vaccin dès que monsieur
poutine a déclaré la création de vac
sens unique vais à cette annonce a été
mal reçue a été suivi des réponses
critiquer sous prétexte que les russes
sont à en date sont pressés pour
résoudre des problèmes géopolitiques
mais au fur et à mesure d'utilisation de
cet accent le comportement a changé ce
qui a été facilité par le fait est que
dès le début
après l annonce par le président de ce
succès des scientifiques russes
il a proposé tout de suite concenant
créer une coopération multilatérale dans
le domaine ollières je n'ai parlé avec
blink mais nous avons aussi parlé de ce
sujet au despotique
il nous a félicités avec le succès ces
vaccins et nous avons a décidé de
promouvoir et à développer les contacts
entre nos scientifiques et pour voir si
on a la possibilité de coopérer dans le
domaine avec nos collègues européens
nous avons déjà des contacts assez
développée à ce sujet à plusieurs pays
sont intéressés à acheter le vac sens et
à organiser la produc la fabrication des
vaccins sur les territoires la
chancelière merkel durant sa
conversation téléphonique avec le
président poutine
c'est à prononcer favorable à voir les
opportunités à ce sujet entre la russie
et l'allemagne
l'institut gamal et est déjà en contact
avec les fabricants de astrazeneca pour
voir la possibilité de créer en une
version combiné de vaccin qui pourrait à
unir les points forts de chaque fac sans
respectifs
alors je crois non seulement que la
coopération peut y jouer un rôle positif
je pense que c'est déjà le cas et ne
font que le féliciter et l'encourager au
ministre termine chinois donné mon
commentaire à ce sujet moi j'ai pris
cette parole uniquement pour féliciter
la russie et que ce succès ce qui est
propice pour l'humanité entière
ah ça nous offre encore un outil à
lutter contre la pandémie
j'étais heureux à lire les rapports
scientifiques et publiés
dans une revue prestigieuse scientifique
lens est à l'article qui a été consacré
à une haute efficacité du vaccin russe
et j'espère que maintenant l'agencé
européenne des médicaments sur est en
mesure de a donné le sens autorisé
l'utilisation de ce vaccin sur le
territoire des pays faisant partie de
l'union
ça nous donnerait une bonne nouvelle
parce que qu'on vous le savez le voir
nous manque maintenant est juste y en a
de nouveau à féliciter les scientifiques
russes pour leur succès merci la
première question à monsieur borel cela
prouve a promis de vous transmettre les
vidéos avec les dispersion des
manifestations en europe
est ce que vous avez pu regarder ses
vidéos et est ce que vous croyez que
vous avez le droit de critiquer les
autorités russes et quels sont vos
objectifs
quand je critique elle a aussi parce que
les responsables ont expliqué qu'elles
n'allaient pas non seulement vous
écouter même prendre en compte ce que
vous dites et j'ai une question à
monsieur lavoie vous savez dit qu' il
s'agit d'une mise à zéro des relations
avec l union européenne mais maintenant
l'union européenne par de soi-disant 1
506 formulée par madame marie reynier
est ce que la russie a une liste de
principe par lesquels elle est guidé
dans ses relations avec l'union
européenne et j'ai aussi une question
sur la vidéo transmise à monsieur brel à
votre homologue suédoise est ce que cela
vous ressemble la vieille blague de
critiquer la nôtre
alors je n'ai pas eu la possibilité de
visionner ces vidéos qui a été présenté
par les autorités russes
il est évident que les âges excessif de
la force a lieu non seulement en russie
je pense que si des vidéos paris et ont
été fondés moynier l'excès d'utilisation
de force me devons condamner ces actes
comme toujours lorsqu'il s'agit de
violation du principe de la primauté de
la loi et c'est le seul tribunal le
système judiciaire qui doit faire le
ménage et engager des responsabilités
compris les responsabilités politiques
pour les personnes qui ont commis en
conduite dans l'approprier jeu déjà
plusieurs fois mentionné ce sujet alors
est ce principe qui dit que les
relations avec la russie seront en forme
lorsque les relations les accords de
mise que si on respectait par à la
russie et c'est bien ce qui me dit que
les accords 2000 ce que ça me plaît pas
mais faut le garder pour garder les
sanctions à c'est une guet-apens qui est
assez illustratif et nos questions
adressées à berlin paris comme le co
rédacteurs de ces accords de mise que en
fait leur opinion envers ses propos de
zelensky à ça reste sans réponse
je comprends pourquoi parce qu pour
toute personne raisonnable il devient
tout à fait clair qu'il s'agit d'une
condition tout à fait artificiers les
quais a été introduit dans les cinq qui
est un principe de frédéric à grigny là
où on stipule que l'union européenne ait
fait la coopération sélectif avec la
fédération de russie alors moi je je
poserai plutôt pas les principaux
opposants
je propose à nous faire guider par les
normes et les principes de la charte de
l'onu et lé cadre de la législation
internationale et compris senki et
autres documents à qui englobe tout sur
des questions de non-ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures intérieur
l'engagement à assurer l'accès libre à
l'information ce qui ne voyons pas
actuellement parmi nos collègues
occidentaux et beaucoup d'autres
secteurs y compris le dialogue égal et
la recherche des coopérations à eauze
enterré comme en hausse et font de
pierre angulaire de tout dialogue qui
vise à résoudre le problème
ea non je ne tenons pas à trouver des
avantages politiques ou autres profit il
est important qu'il lui faut il faut
d'être mutuellement lorsque venait de
souvenir une anecdote à soviétique
et chez vous on fait lyncher des années
noires bon s'il s'agit de protéger les
droits de l'homme s'il s'agit de
d'interdire les essais de force
ces images
que nous avons envoyé à nos collègues
regardée aux états unis en 4 4 policiers
passent par dessus les manifestants
couché par sol et c'est cette image
lorsque anne italie on lance en jets
d'eau contre une manifestante qui est
ensuite heurter contre un mur et en
singles et en russie vous le voyez pas
les forces de l'ordre ont été attaquées
de multiples fois elle est agressée et
non pas utiliser des moyens spéciaux y
compris de gaz lacrymogènes c'étaient
les manifestants qui ont pulvérisé du
gaz lacrymogènes contre la police si ça
vous intéresse vraiment tout ce qui est
et dans le domaine de d'assurer les
droits de l'homme et le droit à
l'information hier avec tony blinken
j'ai parlé ce sujet et léa a entamé la
situation est liée avec le sien navalni
et d un manifestant g on lui pose et qui
je lui ai posé une question concernant
les lieux de détention de ces 400 à peu
près 400 personnes qui sont détenus à
qui sont pas encore sûrs et après cette
attaque contre capitale où plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux sont accusés de
crimes à à qui peut être aux punis de
plusieurs dizaines d'années de prison
où sont-ils détenus il s'agit pas de se
faire guider par les nerfs en europe si
on a à plusieurs situations où les
tribunaux sont soupçonnés d'avoir
apporté en jugement politisé sens être
au fond c'est bien sûr je porte votre
attention à ce que nous n'avons jamais a
mentionné dans nos déclarations
publiques et cette situation avec les
trois détenus qui ont été condamnés en
espagne pour avoir organisé le
référendum en catalogne
et nous nous avons été accusés d'avoir
organisé d'avoir en syrie ces processus
là je vois que le tribunal a été accusée
d'être instrumentalisés à ce qui
concerne ses 1,3 accusé l'oea
juridiction de belgique et d'autres pays
on entendre et c'est la demande à la
tribune à l'espagnol pour annuler ce
jugement qu'il croyait être politisée
l'espagne a répondu que le jugement
était porté en bonne et due forme
conformément à la législation interne
c'était ça et c'est juste ça ce que nous
voulons de la part de nos partenaires
européens
aujourd'hui nous sommes petits noms dans
ce sujet que l'occident veut mettre à
l'arrière plan en se concentrant à des
protestations et à des manifestations en
russie il s'agit de trouver à la vérité
en au sujet de novell inc
quand et où cette soi-disant en pause le
mans a eu lieu les médecins civils
russes et allemands n'ont pas trouvé des
preuves des substances qui aurait été
entre by pense son organisme
ce ne sont plus des médecins militaires
qui ont trouvé quelque chose
nous nous avons adressé de multiples
demandes de nous envoyer les résultats
de ces analyses émis un souhait ni
l'allemagne signé les experts de
l'organisation d'interdiction des armes
chimiques me
son rayon présenter cette arrogance de
la part de l'europe ce thème entre ont
toujours le haut niveau culturel presque
inacceptable si nos collègues nos
partenaires ne ne crois pas être digne
de recevoir cette information qui
pourrait confirmer les accusations
lancées contre hulot ça restera alors à
leur conscience
nous sommes pour la transparence la
franchise
nous n'allons pas à énumérer tous ces
principes c'est pas le sens de maths
comprenons tous de quoi il s'agit
dernière question
lagence l'espagnol la f1 derrière blue
question anglais je tiens à faire une
manifestation pacifique est la dernière
question porte sur les sanctions
selon vous le numéro pun peut-elle
imposer des sanctions contre 8 personnes
à qui figure sur la liste des oligarques
sur la sphère navalni merci je peux
redire ce que j'ai dit ce que j'ai déjà
dit il est évident que nous avons parlé
du dossier navalni et des
interpellations des manifestants et j'ai
fait part à mes yeux les rov de ma plus
profonde préoccupation en rappelant à
libérer navalni et à assurer une enquête
séparant de son empoisonnement
je vais déjà dit au début de notre
conférence de presse je pense qu'une
enquête complète et transparente or
pourrait faire le jour à cette tentative
d'empoisonnement de messieurs navalni
nous pouvons le ru dire d autrefois
mais la question persiste en ce qui
concerne les sanctions pour le moment
aucun état membre de l'union européenne
n'a pas donné ses propositions mais
cette discussion sera poursuivie lors de
la réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères aussi bien qu à la réunion du
mode mars ou qu'on s'était déjà dit
aujourd'hui des points importants des
relations entre l'union européenne et la
russie seront aussi discutés et âme à
béziers d'aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de travaux préparatifs pour cet
événement important aujourd'hui
durant notre entretien avec le monsieur
monsieur le ministre nous avons à
envisager les voiles et de notre future
coopération nonobstant les différends
qui restent à un niveau international et
bilatérale il est important de noter que
nous avons des points communs et des
vecteurs de coopération moi aussi j'ai
déjà parlé à ce sujet je vais pas donner
de multiples commentaires
il s'agit de navalni des protestations
et des double poids deux mesures dans la
couverture médiatique qui est occidental
six espaces en russie les médias
étrangers montrent les réactions de la
police sans montrer ce ces actes
auxquels elle régit et lorsqu'il me
couvrent les manifestations en occident
c'est le contraire on démontre que des
débordements de la part des manifestants
sans montrer l'érection de la police
mais il me semble qu'actuellement on
commence à nous entendre
mais est la position solidaire collectif
de l'union européenne de ne pas nous
présenter de fait je comprends que c'est
la position d'ubs et relance et l'ont
repris cette position du but sans le
cacher la france suède ont suivi cette
7e ces directions et compte tenu du
principe de célérité de solidarité cette
position ne m'étonne pas mais je suis
persuadé que les raisonnabilité de cette
position est comprise par la majorité
des politiques qui en europe
cette obscurité est clair pour tout le
monde aussi 6,11 à rentrer dans le cadre
du respect du droit international le
droit roman qui est utilisé par
plusieurs pays
c'est celui qui accuse qui doit
présenter des arguments et des preuves
c'est tout en ce qui concerne les
sanctions
je dois dire un cul ne le considérons
qu'on me la faire antérieure de l'union
européenne nous avons déjà cette
habitude de voir l'union européenne de
faire à usage des restrictions
unilatérales sans fondement légitime et
alors maintenant nous ne basons à
l'opinion que l'union européenne n'est
pas un partenaire fiable
j'espère que ce dialogue que nous sommes
en train de construire sera prêté
l'attention de l'union européenne à ses
propres intérêts je pense que notre
entretien d'aujourd'hui ne permettra à
prendre une trajectoire plus constructif
nous y sommes prêts et pour conclure en
m'adressant aux journalistes je dois
dire que c'est un passe ce problème
autour des résultats des analyses et qui
ont été réalisées en allemagne en france
et en suède
je suis frappée en fait parce que les
journalistes qui souvent horse prête
attention à 2 petit détail et en profite
dans leurs articles et leurs questions
adressées à aux différends politiques
politiciens à ce sujet les journalistes
sont plutôt passif je comprends pas des
raisons et j'espère que cette curiosité
qui est propre aux journalistes et l
heure à leur volonté à trouver les fêtes
que c'est que ces deux cartes et à ses
propres journalistes prendront le dessus
et ci est ce qu'il existe dans le monde
une situation pareille lorsqu'en
politiciens ou une personne qui
prétendent être politicien exige de la
part des états est rangée de dents pgd 5
sion a son propre pays alors c'est un
sujet important à développer ces
quelques entre vous qu'elle quelques
journalistes veut creuser ce sujet je
pense que à l'article
grand succès et pour conclure je veut
accentuer ce que je retiens de dire
n'oubliez pas que de bonnes nouvelles ne
sont pas ne sont pas très bien vendu ce
sont les scandales qu'on veut mais
aujourd'hui nous avons des bonnes
nouvelles
il s'agit des domaines de la santé de la
science d'éducation des changements
climatiques qui sont au coeur des
intérêts des acteurs majeurs du
continent européen et eurasiatique et
j'espère que c'est enterré à trouveront
seront mises en pratique dans les
accords au confort de tous les
participants
je tiens encore une fois dois remercier
josé pc une équipe et vous pour votre
participation à cette conférence de
presse merci la conférence de presse est
terminée